Jesse Diggins and keek and Randall beat
Sweden by nineteen hundreds of a second
in the women's teen sprint in
Pyeongchang the victory came in Keegan's
fifth and final Olympics and Jesse's
second time on sports biggest stage the
only other American to medal in
cross-country skiing at the Olympics was
Bill Cook he won silver back in 1976
[ __ ] and Jesse of the US Ski and
Snowboard Team are with us at the table
good morning and congratulations ladies
thank you yeah tell me because I will
never know the feeling myself what is it
like to win your first gold medal better
than we could have ever imagined I mean
we've we've been looking forward to this
in the cross-country team for a long
long time we've known it's possible but
to finally put it together and get that
validation for all our programs from
working for you be able to represent our
team it's a dream come true well they're
describing it Alex as a David and
Goliath moment that this was really
astonishing what you two have done it
was intimidating for sure going into
that Sprint's out knowing okay here's
the girl who won World Championships
last year and the Swedish girl won the
Olympic gold in the sprint event yeah
earlier that week so you know you're
going up against some serious heavy
hitters but I really believe in our team
and our chances and we just I mean you
know when your body feels invincible
when you're in the best shape of your
life and you just have to go for it when
your body feels invincible what can one
do to get there yeah did you know that
at any part during the race or just at
that moment and what's the name of that
lunge at the end called is does it have
a special name when you were going
through it that this was gonna be or did
you not really know it until it was all
over this is gonna be the gold medal win
we we had a great day together leading
into the race just created a really good
vibe our teammates were with us
throughout the day we watched our
favorite Glee clips right before we
headed off the race we pulled on our
relay socks which have become a
tradition Jesse did the face paint and
the glitter glitter and so we really
just went in with just a plan and
confidence to ski a smart clean race
never talked about the medals but kind
of knew deep down that if we put the
right day together anything was possible
all the Olympics sports are require
grueling training but cross-country
skiing I mean even to the layman is
really hard stuff you have a
two-year-old how did you do this as a
mother you're the only mom on Team USA
well I really created it being in a
sport like cross-country that it truly
is an amazing lifestyle I mean yes it
takes years and years to get to the top
it's a full-time commitment and being a
mom now I've got to manage that with it
with a toddler but overall I've got this
amazing community of support around me
my team is helping raise my son the fact
that we get to do it as a family and you
know taking him out there and carry him
on my back is really just helped me are
stronger than ever you were calling it
the Nordic lifestyle but now you're
hoping both of you all are hoping your
team's hoping that now it gets national
attention and people in this country
will have a greater understanding and
greater appreciation for what you do you
even think World Cup USA oh that's my
biggest dream is to get to compete in
the States on home soil bringing the
World Cup back here would be the coolest
thing because it would really inspire
the next generation and show them that
yes like we've shown that it's possible
and we've known for a long time it's
possible but being able to bring the
gold medals back and share that with
everyone and then get everyone to see
the World Cup right there
but key can inspire you because you
asked for her autograph when you were 10
16 do you remember seeing her for the
first time keek and thinking what about
her I do I came back from the World Cup
a week early I was in my hometown the
Junior Nationals were there I was on
side the course and I saw this little
ponytail come skiing down the trail I
don't know I do she was but I
immediately recognized she had the right
energy and I thought that girl is gonna
be good someday I didn't know that three
years later she'd be on the world
championship team with me and I never
envisioned that we'd be teaming up to
win a gold medal for Team USA but yep I
I saw that energy early on and I think
about for you Jesse to admire somebody
and now she's a peer a colleague of
yours I feel like the luckiest girl in
the world because I have all these
amazing big sisters and role models and
this this ski
family in my life that I never could
have had if I wasn't a cross-country
skier and I I'm sure I was super
annoying pestering them with so many
questions you know what do you what do
you do between the sprint heats why are
you sleeping right now what is happening
what should I do what stocks should I
wear what foot does stripe go on but
it's so cool to have the chance now to
be able to pass that on and get to be
the one answering questions I'm just
asking them all the time that is the
question now which is how does this all
start people know about the bunny slopes
for downhill skiing but say I wanted to
start where how did this start for you
well it's so cool because cross-country
skiing similar to running maybe not
everyone can do it at the Olympic level
but at the entry level anyone can do it
and like you said earlier like maybe not
everyone can take a bobsled run or go
off a ski jump but everyone can try and
cross-country skiing and so if my
parents were super into it and so when I
was just a baby they were skiing around
with me and their backpack and I was
pulling on my dad's here and telling him
to mush like he was a sled dog and
thanks to you ladies there's a whole
generation of young women wholly brush
country skiers that's big and thick you
can Randle congratulations go team USA